in the last video we gave a bit of an
overview of potassium argon dating in
this video i want to go through a
concrete example it'll get a little bit
mathy usually involving a little bit of
algebra or a little bit of exponential
decay but to really show you how you can
actually figure out the age of some
volcanic rock using this technique using
a little bit of mathematics
so we know that anything that is
experiencing radioactive decay it's
experiencing exponential decay and we
know that we can there's a generalized
way to describe that and we go into more
depth and kind of prove it in other khan
academy videos but we know that the
amount
the amount as a function of time so if
we say n is the amount of a radioactive
sample we have at some at some time we
know that's equal to the initial amount
we have we'll call that n sub zero times
e to the negative kt
where this constant is particular to
that thing's half-life and to figure it
out and we're going to do this for the
example of potassium 40 we know that
after when time is 1.25 billion years
that the amount we have left is half of
our initial amount so let's write it
that way so let's say when we we start
with n naught we start with not whatever
that might be might be one gram kilogram
five grams whatever it might be whatever
we start with we take e to the negative
k times 1.25 billion years that's the
half-life of potassium 40.
so 1.25 billion years we know after that
long that half of the sample will be
left so we will have one half
one half and not left whatever we
started with we're going to have half
left after 1.25 billion years divide
both sides by n naught divide both sides
by n naught and then to solve for k we
can take the natural log of both sides
so you get the natural log
of one half we don't have that n naught
there anymore is equal to the natural
log of this thing the natural log is
just saying to what power do i have to
raise e to get e to the negative k times
1.25 billion so the natural log of this
the power that i have to raise e2 to get
e get to e to the negative k times 1.25
billion is just negative k times 1.25
billion i could write it as negative
1.25
let me write it times 10
to the ninth
times 10 to the ninth k that's the same
thing as 1.25 billion we have our
negative sign and we have our k
and then to solve 4k we can divide both
sides by negative 1.25 billion
and so we get k and i'll just flip the
sides here k is equal to the natural log
of one half times negative
1.25
times 10 to the ninth power and what we
can do is we can multiply the negative
times the top or you could view it as
multiplying the
numerator and the denominator by
negative so the negative shows up at the
top and so we could make this as over
1.25
times 10 to the ninth it's just 1.25
billion and negative let me write it
over here in a different color
negative
the negative natural log well i could
just write it this way if i have a
natural log of b we know from our
logarithm properties this is the same
thing as the natural log of b
to the a power so the negative natural
log of one-half is the same thing as the
natural log of one-half to the negative
one power and so this is the same thing
anything to the negative 1 power is just
this multiplicative inverse so this is
just the natural log of 2. so negative
natural log of 1 half is just the
natural log of 2 over here so we were
able to figure out our k it's
essentially the natural log of 2 over
the half-life of this substance so we
could actually generalize this if we're
talking about some other radioactive
substance and now let's think about a
situation
now that we've figured out a k
let's think about a situation where we
find in some sample so let's say the
potassium that we find let's say it is
one milligram i'm just going to make up
these numbers and let's say and usually
these aren't measured directly and you
really care about the relative amounts
but let's say you're able to figure out
the potassium is one milligram and let's
say that the argon actually let me say
the potassium 40 found let's say the
argon 40 found let's say it is 0.01
0.0
milligram so how do we how can we use
this information and what we just
figured out here which is derived from
the half-life to figure out how old how
old this sample right over here how do
we figure out how old this sample is
right over there well what we what we
need to figure out we know that n
we know that n the amount we were left
with is this thing right over here so we
know that we're left with one milligram
so we know that what we have left is one
milligram and that's going to be equal
to some initial amount it's going to be
some initial amount when we'll use both
of this information to figure that
initial amount out times e to the
negative k
t
and we know what k is and we'll figure
it out later so k is this thing right
over here so we need to figure out what
our initial amount is we know what k is
and then we can solve for t how old is
this sample and to figure out our
initial amount we just have to remember
that for every
for every argon 40 we see
that must have decayed from when when
you have potassium 40 11 after 11 decays
when it decays 11 percent decays into
argon 40 and the rest 89 decays into
calcium 40. we saw that in the last
video so however much argon 40 that is
11 of the decay product so if you want
to think about the total number of
potassium 40s that have decayed since
this was since this was kind of stuck in
the in the lava and we learned that
anything that was there before any argon
40 those there before would have would
have been able to get out of the liquid
lava before it froze or before it
hardened so to figure out how much how
much potassium 40 this is derived from
we just derive it we divide it by 11
percent so maybe i could say
k
k initial the potassium 40 initial is
going to be equal to the amount of
potassium 40 we have today one milligram
plus the amount of potassium 40 we
needed to get this amount of argon 40.
so we have this amount of argon 40 0.01
milligrams and that the number of
milligrams there it's really just 11 of
the original potassium potassium 40 that
it had to come from the rest of it
turned into calcium 40. so we divide it
by 11
or 0.11 and i'm doing this isn't the
exact number but it'll get the general
idea
and so our initial which is really this
thing right over here i could call this
n naught
i could call this n naught this is going
to be equal to and i won't do any of the
math so we have 1
milligram we have left is equal to
1 milligram which is what we found plus
0.01 milligram
over
0.11
and then all of that times
e to the negative
e to the negative kt
and what you see here is when we want to
solve for t assuming we know k and we do
know k now that it really the absolute
amount doesn't matter what actually
matters is the ratio because if we're
solving for t you want to divide both
sides of this equation by this quantity
right over here so you get this side the
left-hand side divide both sides you get
one milligram over this quantity i'll
write it in blue over this quantity is
going to be one
plus i'm just going to assume actually
that the units here are milligrams
so you get one
over this quantity which is one plus
0.01 over the 11 over the 11 percent
that is equal to e to the negative kt
and then you want to take if you want to
solve for t you want to take the natural
log of both sides
so then you get so this is equal right
over here you want to take the natural
log of both sides so you get the natural
log of 1 over 1 plus 0.01
over
over 0.11 or 11 percent is equal to
negative
kt and then to solve for t you divide
both sides by negative k so i'll write
it over here and you can see it's a
little bit cumbersome mathematically but
we're getting to the answer so we got
the natural log of 1 over 1 plus 0.01
over .11
over negative k
well what is negative k we're just
dividing both sides of this equation by
negative k negative k is the negative of
this over the negative natural log of 2
over 1.25
times 10 to the ninth and now we can get
our calculator out and just solve for
what this time is and it's going to be
in years because that's how we figured
out this constant so let's
get out my handy ti 85
and so
first i'll do this part so this is 1
divided by
plus
0.01
divided by 0.11 so that's this part
right over here
that gives us
that number and then we want to take the
natural log of that
so let's take the natural log of our
this is just our previous answer so it's
the natural log of 0.9166667
gives us negative
.087 so that's this numerator over here
and we're going to divide that so this
number is our numerator right over here
we're going to divide that by the
negative let me make i'll use
parentheses carefully the negative
natural log of 2 the negative natural
log of 2 that's that there divided by
divided by 1.258
times 10 to the ninth
so divided by so it's negative natural
log of 2 divided by 1.25 e 9 means times
10 to the ninth and i closed both
parentheses and now we need our drum
roll so this should give us our t in
years
and we get
let's see how many this is this is
thousand so it's three thousand so we
get 156
million or 156.9 million years if we
round
so this is approximately i could just
say approximately 157
million years
old sample so the whole point of this i
know the math was a little bit involved
but it's something that you would
actually see in kind of a precalculus
class or an algebra 2 class when you're
studying exponential growth and decay
but the whole point i wanted to do this
is to show you that it's not some crazy
voodoo here and you know sal gave this
very high level explanation and then you
say oh well you know there must be some
super difficult mathematics after that
the mathematics really is something that
you would see in high school and if you
saw if you saw a sample that had this
ratio of argon 40 to potassium 40 you
would actually be able to do that fairly
you know that high school mathematics
you would able to do that to figure out
this is a 157
million year old sample of volcanic rock